crying is a definitely my weak point I
hate crying I hate crying in front of
anyone but then yeah if I show that I'm
crying in front of you ooh felt like I
lost the game you know the first you
know I remember the first time you
actually bawled in front of me do you
remember you you actually don't ball in
front of me away just like teary but no
this is you actually crying you went it
was when we when I was living in the
Cape Town spot uh-huh and you already
opened up to me the fact that you
there's a period in your life where you
gained a lot of weight and you didn't
like yourself image and this is when I
was bigger and I was trying to lose
weight by doing macros and you didn't
understand what macros were I don't know
whether you believed it it or not or or
whatever you didn't like my methodology
so I would put in my macros and I was
losing weight through you know just
managing my fat calories and whatever
right and it was working here and there
but then I was I don't know what
happened with the way we were
communicating back in the day but either
way we got into an argument but I
remember the feeling that I took away
from it from the argument was that you
were making it difficult for me to
really love myself and you were hurting
my self-image and I remember what I said
to you was that I said you should know
what it feels like to be overweight and
not not like the way you look but
however you felt then is how you make me
feel when you talk to me about my weight
and then you got really quiet and then
you just started tearing up and you went
and you started bawling while you were
laying in my bed you were bawling and
then you know after you were crying I
couldn't figure out why you feel bad
about your way yeah what was I saying
you just I think you were just and this
was before this is not when you were the
biggest no this was like a year into our
relationships and you just I remember
you crying because you felt that you
were being a bully and then you were you
were kind of hurting my self-image a lot
bawling your eyes out you remember that
you were crying that was the first time
I ever
saw you just full-out cry in front of me
holy cow how come I don't remember this
but it must been a really good girl it's
a cry because I felt bad for being a
bully that I didn't really I felt really
bad but you've never ever since then you
never really mentioned anything about my
weight you know to tell you the truth I
grew up mice around like my friends or
anyone yeah my sir my friends or the
guys who I've dated I have to say I
didn't have everybody was fairly active
I didn't have anyone who was big or just
overweight overweight just inactive just
yeah we care too much activity it was
actually a shock that I was with a fat
guy I was falling in love with this guy
who I'm just like I don't know if I'm I
honestly I was like I don't know if I'm
physically attracted to this oh [ __ ]
okay well that hurts no no but that was
true that's true that's true they
probably that's why I seeped out like
that because I've never dated anyone who
was overweight so I was like this is
weird I don't know why I'm still dating
this guy because I think I really
enjoyed your personality yeah and I
think that was most girls maybe and I
was trying to see you like if I this is
gonna last and honestly yeah I think
that's what it is for both of us like
for the first at least a year or two
like we were seeing if we were a match
for each other yeah and the first year
it was a struggle for me I don't think
I've ever told you about like I was just
not sure if I was going to be fully
committed to this relationship because I
don't know if I was attracted to you oh
really completely what just because of
the physical part yeah because
physically I just wasn't sure if I was
attracted to you now it's a different
story like I well I guess like
physically if you didn't feel physically
attracted me you sure as hell kiss me a
lot not the first year first year Yeah
right yeah I don't know well that's the
thing it was like slowly gradually as
the more I got to know you the more that
didn't become apparent more do you feel
like back then when you were younger you
were maybe a little bit too focused on
looks shallow yeah no shallow I think so
cuz I didn't know who you were yeah I
was getting to know you and I liked what
I was seeing on the inside but I was
like but it wasn't enough for me to not
think about physical attraction yeah I
feel a lot of people get weirded out
when somebody says then for me when you
tell me that like I'm not even offended
by that and I understand because I think
that sometimes when you are it's too
late it's too late we've been together
for such a long time
but I feel like when people sometimes
hear that they you know they get
disappointed an individual who says
things like that openly but you know
physical attraction is a huge part of
being in a relationship and I'm not
saying that's for everybody some people
they go it's never about looks cool well
that's for you some people that physical
attraction part matters it matters and I
eat even matters for me too I'm not
gonna lie even though I look like a sea
monster I still wanted to be with the
pretty person you look like my Pooh Bear
oh now I do yeah you know and I think
for you it's big for me I mean I can't
speak for you but if I were to interpret
it's because you were so active and you
were so adamant about your health like
there was a certain point where you were
just making all healthy recipes and it
was something that made you happy and
now something that you couldn't share
with me yeah you know and it probably
made you sad too that there's somebody
who like a representation of like maybe
for you my dedication or non dedication
to fitness was also representation that
I didn't care about myself and so and I
understand and I didn't care about
myself in that sense like I didn't care
enough about how being overweight was
affecting me you know and even even now
you even know there's two and I didn't
notice this until you mentioned it when
when I lost even the first thirty pounds
my attitude was different this round
room this round oh yeah you know I
didn't know that I didn't know how much
how man you have no idea how hard it was
when you were at your max weight when I
wasn't what two years ago now yeah how
come you never well I guess it's hard to
mention it right I mean I mean you
didn't mention it but yeah I didn't
mention it but it wasn't I think that
year was probably one of the hardest
emotional it was kind of hard because
you were going through a lot with your
career and that was affecting your
health
and I could clearly see the correlation
between those two and was it miserable
you were yeah and you were trying so
many things and like I couldn't tell you
to stop anything because I don't have an
answer for you and eating was your way
to relief your stress and that all I
could do was just kind of be there for
you because you weren't gonna listen to
anyone either way you had to go through
it realize that what you what you like
and when you don't like and I was just
there for you regardless and it was kind
of hard for me because I could see that
you're going down with your health and I
was like concerned about that but I
think once you have realized it and you
know towards the end of the year I did
tell you like how I felt about you know
how you're doing with your health and
like your work in our quality time like
you rarely had time for us and so I you
know I could see that you're you were
becoming very weak and I couldn't become
weak with you I couldn't go along with
that like someone had to be the stronger
end right and so you know I got to a
point where it's like I think we need to
sit down and talk about this and what I
realized is that even though that was
your Vegas weight which if I look at it
again right now like it's just look like
me it is amazing how much I did not see
that to like I saw that you were gaining
a lot of weight but I didn't see I was
like disgusting person I saw you I was
like someone who's trying super hard to
make things work yeah and I wanted to be
there for you yeah and I realized that's
when I hit me I was like I don't think I
really care about like whether he's big
or not like I just want to make sure
that he's happy you know and when she
says like disgusting - it's not it's not
big you know like the fat would make me
disgusting it was my behavior yeah how I
carried myself my attitude there was
just a lot of things that were just
going downhill and you know I couldn't
and even then - it was hard for me to be
vulnerable with you because I wanted to
be a strong figure in your life you know
I wanted to be the strong boyfriend and
I didn't want to show you that side
either and you know for me to be honest
with you the person that probably helped
me I mean you and Vanessa were the two
biggest people that helped me lose the
weight the most right because Vanessa if
you guys don't know who vanessa is
vanessa is my was my former assistant
sweetest girl so sweet as she I
my assistant she's like my baby sister
I'd loved this girl to death she was one
of those people that just had to she had
to deal with my [ __ ] the most she was
there throughout the whole thing and
there was a point where I was just
giving her a paycheck just to help me
just to be around and just do [ __ ] for
me like I didn't need her to do it but I
was so it wasn't such a bright I just
needed her dude they couldn't get out of
bed you were spread and I was spread so
thin you know I was trying to do the act
it was just it was just so much you know
and I knew that you didn't want to show
your weakness okay like I know that you
were tire exhausted but you don't want
to show that so I'm just there kind of
just being there yeah being your
girlfriend being the girl who you know
you want to get out of that a stress so
you know you come to me or you come you
go to Vanessa and I just that's all I
wanted to do for you and that's all I
could do you know which was really hard
it was hard I think it affected a lot of
Paulo you know big huge parts of our
relationship like quality time was the
hardest thing I was just so distracted I
didn't and I was trying to distract
myself with anything and everything to
avoid the fact that I was gaining weight
I wasn't feeling good and I just didn't
I didn't know what to do you know well I
mentioned this under earlier podcast but
I listened to this podcast with Joe
Rogan where they had this guy named
David Goggins on there and David Goggins
this former Navy SEAL he and his story
is insane but basically he was 300
pounds he was heavier than I was and he
he actually failed going into the
military multiple times and he his story
was so inspiring and I think the thing
that hit me the most was hit what he
told me was you're not you're kind of
just a lot of people just kind of race
against other people but they never you
know kind of raced against themselves
yeah so your don't be the best at what
other people tell you to be be the best
that you can be and then kind of measure
yourself with that and it was and he
kind of had the stops like are you happy
he goes are you really happy mm-hmm
you know are you happy being this person
you know can you really live the rest of
your life being this human being and
yeah what are the things that you're
gonna do to make it happen and change
and if you are truly happy with it then
like you know what are all these things
that are making you feel this way and I
just you know something about the way
that he spoke to me and I you know he
speak he's very harsh I think he's a
maniac but and it doesn't work for
everybody else but that's how I
communicate so it worked well with me
what's crazy is that I think there are a
lot of friends who are concerned
including myself and kind of talk to you
but this random stranger is the one who
inspired you and it clicked in your head
be like okay I need to change my life
and you listen to his podcast as it was
his podcast on the Joe Rogan podcast
resync today I listen to that podcast
you warship that podcast i I listen